intérieur la parole et amram isabelle le
callennec
[Applaudissements]
attendez une minute
merci
madame local des nac breda par oui merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre un million
deux cent mille chômeurs de plus depuis
mai 2012 force est de constater qu'en
matière de lutte contre le chômage vous
avez tout essayé sauf ceux qui marchent
vos éléments de langage pour justifier
les chiffres du mois d'août n'ont
convaincu personne à y ait l'honnêteté
de reconnaître qu'on ne va pas mieux
vous avez pourtant usé et abusé de tous
les artifices pour tenter de dissimuler
cette triste réalité recours massif aux
emplois aidés on vient d'en parler plan
cinq cent mille chômeurs en formation
interprétation des chiffres leur groupe
l'est républicain se demandent ce que
vous allez bien pouvoir inventer de
nouveaux pour tenter de faire croire
coûte que coûte à une inversion à courbe
du chômage censée sauver le soldat
hollande en annonçant ce mercredi son
projet de budget pour 2010 est votre
ministre des finances nous a mis sur la
piste vous allez enjoliver les
perspectives de croissance le taux
exagérément optimiste de 1,5 pour cent
est contestée par le fmi par l' ocde par
le haut conseil les finances publiques
qui jugent vos objectifs improbable
c'est imprudent ajoutez à cela
l'ouverture en grand des vannes de la
dépense publique al'approche de la
présidentielle vous n'avez plus aucune
chance hélas de redresser la situation
économique et sociale de notre pays les
français l'ont bien compris qui à vrai
dire n'attendent plus rien de votre
gouvernement à l'heure de régler les
comptes de quinquennat
je pose une question
qui du président de la république des
premiers ministres ou des ministres
successifs de l'économie et des finances
sont les véritables responsables de ce
terrible échec et ne pas que c'est la
faute à pas de chance
la parole est à monsieur michel sapin
christian eckert secrétaire d'état
chargé du budget
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée mesdames messieurs les députés
vous parler d'échec en matière de
compliquer puisque c'était le sens de
votre question souvenez vous un déficit
public européen d un constant au-delà
des 5% dans les années 2011 c'est à dire
avant notre arrivée aujourd'hui ramené
cette année à 3.3 j'observe d'ailleurs
puisque vous avez mis en doute vous avez
mis en doute la crédibilité des
propositions du gouvernement dans la loi
de finances observe d'ailleurs que le
haut construit des finances publiques
s'il a parlé de 2017 n'a aucunement
remis en doute nos prévisions pour 2016
l'année n'est pas terminée qui devrait
nous conduire à un déficit de 3 3 % ce
qui est pas loin de la moitié de ce que
nous avons trouvé en avant et ce déficit
a concerné du mois sa réduction a
concerné l'ensemble des secteurs de
l'économie et nous l'avons fait michel
sapin l'a rappelé tout à l'heure à un
rythme qui n'a pas obérer les capacités
d'investissement qui n'a pas obérer les
capacités de croissance qui n'a pas eu
l'effet récessif c'est pour cela que
nous avons obtenus c'est vrai des délais
de la part de la commission c'est parce
que le respect de notre trajectoire tous
les ans nos objectifs ont été respectées
le haut conseil des finances publiques
dont aujourd'hui tout le monde se
gargarise nous avait dit en 2015 que 4
3% de déficit c'était un certain de son
fait
3,5 pour cent de déficit en 2015 alors
madame la députée tous les gouvernements
qu'ils soient seront redevables de cette
amélioration des comptes publics elle
permet dans la durée parce que nous y
reviendrons dans cette séance d'assurer
la soutenabilité de notre système de
protection sociale d'assurer la
croissance tout en donnant à la france
sa crédibilité pour le présent auprès de
nos partenaires européens et pour
l'avenir dans la soutenabilité de sa
dette qui commencent à pleurer